Tasha: 这瓶是矿泉水
Tasha: This bottle is mineral water.
Tasha: 这个很简单
Tasha: This is very simple.
Tasha: 这个是矿泉水
Tasha: This is mineral water.
Tasha: 你不用喝都知道
Tasha: You don't even need to drink it to know.
Tasha: 好 矿泉水
Tasha: Okay, mineral water.
Jake: 我我们找到一些环保的方案哈哈哈
Jake: We've found some eco-friendly solutions, hahaha.
Lucia: 废物利用
Lucia: Recycling waste.
Jake: 太环保了
Jake: So eco-friendly.
Tasha: 这个餐巾纸我想要一张
Tasha: I want a napkin.
Tasha: 这倒的漏出来了水好不好意思
Tasha: I spilled some water, my bad.
Jake: 不差了不差了
Jake: Not bad, not bad.
Jake: 然后这边有好几支笔
Jake: And here are several pens.
Lucia: 我是不是得用这种啊
Lucia: Should I use this one?
Lucia: 你也是可以
Lucia: You can too.
Jake: 你们就换着用
Jake: Just take turns using them.
Jake: 或者有没有纸
Jake: Or does anyone have paper?
Lucia: 这样我就可以用
Lucia: Then I can use it.
Tasha: 这这个是怎么怎么呢
Tasha: How do we do this?
Tasha: 怎么写编号呢
Tasha: How do we number them?
Tasha: 哦哦123456
Tasha: Oh, oh, 123456.
Jake: 对哦嗯
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 我我我我我觉得这个有点小
Jake: I think this one is a bit small.
Lucia: 他写不下啊
Lucia: It won't fit.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 底下还有这种黑纸盒吗
Lucia: Are there any black paper boxes like this below?
Jake: 来这样
Jake: Here, like this.
Lucia: Oh Jesus
Lucia: Oh Jesus.
Shure:  你肯定先避开下一个
Shure: You should definitely avoid the next one.
Tasha: 我觉得这应该写ABCDE
Tasha: I think we should write ABCDE.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 其实你们有些人带着充电宝对吧
Jake: Actually, some of you have portable chargers, right?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Jake: 你自己
Jake: You yourself.
Lucia: 哎这样可以少写好些字对
Lucia: Hey, this way we can write fewer words.
Shure:  这次都不用尝就看出来了啊
Shure: This time we can tell without even tasting, huh?
Katrina:  转一个弯
Katrina: Take a turn.
Katrina:  最纯净哦
Katrina: It's the purest.
Shure:  写写写编号对
Shure: Write the numbers, right.
Lucia: 有的水喝过来没记住那个味怎么办
Lucia: What if I forget the taste of the water I drank?
Tasha: 尝不出来啊
Tasha: Can't tell apart?
Jake: 多尝几次
Jake: Try a few more times
Jake: 哈哈多尝几次
Jake: Haha, try a few more times
Lucia: 喝完了快
Lucia: Hurry up and finish it
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake: 这么这么渴吗
Jake: Are you that thirsty?
Alice: 不是尝尝尝尝
Alice: No, just tasting, tasting
Lucia: 刚好补充水分
Lucia: Just replenishing fluids
Jake: 尝出来了
Jake: Got the taste
Katrina:  鉴酒似的
Katrina: Like a wine tasting
Lucia: 嗯可以可以
Lucia: Hmm, okay, okay
Lucia: 能写就行
Lucia: As long as you can write
Jake: a b c d f
Jake: 我也想尝尝
Jake: I also want to try
Jake: 一会再尝
Jake: Try again later
Jake: 我们一会再尝尝
Jake: We'll try again later
Shure:  摸温度哈哈哈好聪明
Shure: Feeling the temperature, haha, so smart
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: One bottle is really cold
Jake: 啊哦真的
Jake: Oh, really?
Alice: 在哪啊不是在哪洗
Alice: Where is it, not where to wash it
Shure:  我估计应该最冰的是他
Shure: I guess the coldest one is his
Shure:  因为他最大
Shure: Because it's the biggest
Shure:  有没有可能
Shure: Is that possible?
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: One bottle is really cold
Alice: 哎答案写在哪啊
Alice: Hey, where do we write the answers?
Katrina:  掰一下给你
Katrina: Let me break it for you
Alice: 不过我按我的顺序跟他对一下
Alice: But I'll compare it with my order
Katrina:  好这样写
Katrina: Okay, write it like this
Alice: 这是啥呀甲
Alice: What is this, A?
Katrina:  拿这写也行
Katrina: You can write it with this too
Shure:  f
Shure: f
Shure:  这是f的话题
Shure: This is the f topic
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know
Jake: 我乱写
Jake: I wrote it randomly
Tasha: 有白板笔吗
Tasha: Is there a whiteboard marker?
Jake: 样题
Jake: Sample question
Shure:  我绝对不能把我的一包选错
Shure: I absolutely can't choose the wrong package
Lucia: 能从这个圆这瓶里再倒出来喝吗
Lucia: Can we pour it back from this round bottle to drink?
Shure:  疯了
Shure: Crazy
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh
Lucia: 比较一下吗
Lucia: Should we compare them?
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Lucia: 喝完某一个就好了
Lucia: Just finish one and it'll be fine.
Jake: 我们有几位已经整出来了吗感觉
Jake: Do we have a few who are done already, it seems?
Jake: 已经交卷了
Jake: Papers are already handed in.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: So impressive.
Katrina:  主要是我从来
Katrina: Mostly because I never...
Jake: 我看一看建浩老师
Jake: Let me see, Teacher Jianhao.
Jake: 来看你的答案
Jake: Let's see your answer.
Katrina:  哈哈哈鹅
Katrina: Hahaha, goose.
Shure:  猜
Shure: Guess.
Katrina:  主要是全不会
Katrina: Mostly because I don't know any of it.
Katrina:  就跟那种完全没学过一样
Katrina: It's like I never studied.
Katrina:  然后哈哈哈
Katrina: And then, hahaha.
Jake: 就可以替身交卷
Jake: Just submit it as it is.
Shure:  都选c吧
Shure: Just pick C for everything.
Shure:  那不就
Shure: That should...
Katrina:  对啊
Katrina: Yeah, but...
Katrina:  但是都写怡宝
Katrina: But I wrote Yibao for everything.
Katrina:  总有一个对的
Katrina: One of them has to be right.
Lucia: 好有道理
Lucia: That makes so much sense.
Katrina:  矿泉水
Katrina: Bottled water.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Lucia: 我打算都写怡宝
Lucia: I plan to write Yibao for all.
Jake: 哈哈我看看你的怡宝对不对
Jake: Haha, let me see if your Yibao is correct.
Jake: 不知道
Jake: Who knows.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here you go.
Jake: 那我还能怎么说呢
Jake: What else can I say?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's see.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 没看明白
Jake: I don't get it.
Jake: 就是要要倒一下顺序
Jake: We just need to reverse the order.
Shure:  我交卷了老师
Shure: I'm done, teacher.
Jake: 这样吧你们你们按照这个字母12123456
Jake: Okay, let's do it this way, you guys follow the letters 1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Jake: 然后按照字母顺一下
Jake: Then sort them by letters.
Jake: 不然我们这个就是像选择题答案一样
Jake: Otherwise, it's like answering multiple-choice questions.
Jake: 知道吧我们一会对
Jake: You know, we'll...
Jake: 一会我们就会报这个
Jake: We'll announce it later.
Jake: EFCD之类的
Jake: EFCD and so on.
Jake: 这种
Jake: Like that.
Shure:  没问题
Shure: No problem.
Jake: 来写一下
Jake: Let's write it down.
Jake: 没没看明白就是
Jake: If you don't understand, just...
Jake: 交卷
Jake: Turn it in.
Alice: 就是一到六
Alice: It's from one to six.
Jake: 答题卡答题卡
Jake: Answer sheet, answer sheet.
Tasha: 44
Tasha: 44.
Tasha: 1
Tasha: 1.
Tasha: 55
Tasha: 55.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Jake: 给收卷
Jake: Collect the sheets.
Lucia: 纯净水的矿泉水
Lucia: Purified mineral water.
Jake: 好收卷
Jake: Okay, collect the sheets.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Jake: 收卷
Jake: Collect the sheets.
Tasha:D是什么
Tasha: What's D?
Lucia: 卷子没写完
Lucia: The paper isn't finished.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Katrina:  答题卡没涂
Katrina: The answer sheet isn't filled in.
Shure:  答题卡没涂
Shure: The answer sheet isn't filled in.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Jake: 不着急不着急
Jake: Don't worry, don't worry.
Jake: 再品一品
Jake: Let's savor it a bit more.
Tasha: 哎，这个，哎什么玩意
Tasha: Hey, this, hey, what is this?
Shure:  我还有一个同学
Shure: I have a classmate.
Tasha:这样吗
Tasha: Like this?
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  哈哈哈只能喝娃哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, only drink Wahaha.
Lucia: 不好意思三五
Lucia: Sorry, 35.
Tasha: 我就只能喝我就尝出来了娃哈哈的味
Tasha: I can only taste the Wahaha flavor.
Lucia: 一个都尝不出来
Lucia: I can't taste any of them.
Katrina:  我去真的
Katrina: Wow, really.
Alice: 这个可以
Alice: This is good.
Katrina:  这一般是便利店里有
Katrina: This is usually at convenience stores.
Katrina:  什么买哪个便宜卖哪个
Katrina: They sell whatever is cheaper.
Jake: 答题卡是不是都没写名字呀
Jake: Did no one write their names on the answer sheets?
Jake: 谁是谁啊
Jake: Who is who?
Jake: 一会互相面面
Jake: We'll check with each other later.
Jake: 大家都知道
Jake: Everyone knows
Jake: 大家都知道对
Jake: Everyone knows, right?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm
Katrina:  今天我的生日
Katrina: Today is my birthday
Shure:  批卷是吧
Shure: Grading papers, right?
Katrina:  要把这
Katrina: We need to do this
Jake: 批卷准备
Jake: Prepare to grade papers
Jake: 批卷
Jake: Grading papers
Lucia: 这些其他能不能多选一个答案啊
Lucia: Can we choose more than one answer for these?
Lucia: 这样保证至少有对的
Lucia: This way, we'll at least get one right
Jake: 可以啊可以
Jake: Sure, we can do that
Jake: 这个策略是可以的哈哈
Jake: This strategy works, haha
Shure:  快递放在一楼椅子上了
Shure: The package is on the chair on the first floor
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it
Shure:  太有那个高中监考老师那味了
Shure: It really feels like a high school exam proctor
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 走来走去
Tasha: Walking around
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Shure:  在晃悠
Shure: Pacing
Shure:  然后那个拖鞋还咔咔咔的声你知道吗
Shure: And the slippers make this clacking sound, you know?
Tasha: 啪啪啪
Tasha: Clack, clack, clack
Jake: 然后没事看一看你们的答案
Jake: Then occasionally looking at your answers
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah
Katrina:  然后咂一声
Katrina: Then make a sound
Katrina:  嗯然后这个同学就慌
Katrina: And then the student panics
Shure:  然后在他旁边叹口气唉唉
Shure: Then sigh next to him, like "Sigh, sigh"
Alice: 唉
Alice: Sigh
Jake: 再指指点点
Jake: Then pointing
Jake: 这题写错了
Jake: This question is wrong
Tasha: 点 就是不说话
Tasha: Just pointing, no words
Jake: 帮2分呵呵
Jake: Give 2 points, haha
Alice: 也不当就这样
Alice: Not even that, just point
Alice: 就指点一下
Alice: Just point it out
Lucia: 然后就这样吧
Lucia: And then leave it
Jake: 好的互相p吧
Jake: Okay, let's grade each other's papers
Jake: 我们也不想看
Jake: We don't want to look
Shure:  互相p照
Shure: Grade each other's papers
Shure:  我天
Shure: Oh man
Katrina:  我天呐天呐天呐
Katrina: Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god
Shure:  真的是给外国人一些
Shure: It's really for foreigners
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Shure:  这是我自个的
Shure: This is mine
Katrina:  这这不是我的吗
Katrina: Isn't this mine?
Jake: 这是
Jake: It is
Lucia: 啊写了写了
Lucia: Ah, I wrote it down
Shure:  那个我也写这个啊
Shure: I also wrote this down
Lucia: 这我自己认
Lucia: I know this myself
Tasha: 这什么意思啊
Tasha: What does this mean?
Tasha: 看不懂
Tasha: I don't get it
Katrina:  老铁
Katrina: Hey bro
Katrina:  你自由我扯
Katrina: You're free, I get it
Tasha: 三是a是吧
Tasha: Three is A, right?
Jake: 是谁的呀
Jake: Whose is this?
Jake: 真的是你的
Jake: It's really yours
Katrina:  是我的呀
Katrina: It's mine
Tasha: 那他这个e写的是啥呀
Tasha: Then what is this 'E' he wrote?
Lucia: 那是我的哦
Lucia: That's mine
Tasha: 一是c好行
Tasha: One is C, okay
Jake: 好好来
Jake: Okay, come on
Alice: 公布答案
Alice: Reveal the answers
Jake: 公布答案
Jake: Reveal the answers
Jake: 一第一个是
Jake: The first one is
Katrina:  我倒是写了
Katrina: I did write it down
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh man
Jake: 一个是啥呀
Jake: What is the first one?
Alice: 第一个是啥
Alice: What is the first one?
Jake: 第一个是a
Jake: The first one is A
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Jake: 第一个是农夫山泉
Jake: The first one is Nongfu Spring
Jake: 第二个是啥
Jake: What's the second one?
Jake: 第二个是苏打水d嗯
Jake: The second one is soda water, D, yeah
Shure:  这倒是能尝出来嗯
Shure: You can taste that, yeah
Jake: 第三个是百岁山
Jake: The third one is Baishui Mountain
Katrina:  二是b第三是c
Katrina: Two is B, three is C
Jake: c第四个是e
Jake: C, the fourth one is E
Jake: 这个都这不能不对了
Jake: This one can't be wrong
Jake: 第五个是娃哈哈
Jake: The fifth one is Wahaha
Jake: 是b
Jake: It's B
Shure:  你还给人家改
Shure: You're even changing it for them
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina:  不小心就是
Katrina: It was an accident
Lucia: 哎呀这手控制不住
Lucia: Oh no, I can't control my hand
Katrina:  ABC
Katrina: ABC
Jake: 我是不是
Jake: Did I
Jake: 我是不是写错了
Jake: Did I write it wrong
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice: 第六个是啥呀
Alice: What's the sixth one?
Jake: 第六个是
Jake: The sixth one is
Jake: 第六个是娃哈哈
Jake: The sixth one is Wahaha
Lucia: 第六个是娃哈哈
Lucia: The sixth one is Wahaha
Jake: 没有第五个是怡宝
Jake: No, the fifth one is Yibao
Jake: 第五个是怡宝
Jake: The fifth one is Yibao
Jake: 给你们一些surprise
Jake: Giving you guys some surprise
Shure:  第五是怡宝
Shure: The fifth is Yibao
Lucia: 所以第五个是F
Lucia: So the fifth one is F
Jake: 第五是一对
Jake: The fifth is correct
Jake: 第五是f
Jake: The fifth is F
Lucia: 第六个是b
Lucia: The sixth one is B
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Lucia: 好吧我给人家写标上答案写错了
Lucia: Okay, I wrote the answer wrong on the label
Katrina:  哎随便批吧
Katrina: Eh, just mark it randomly
Shure:  你就只错了两个
Shure: You only got two wrong
Katrina:  真的吗纯瞎写
Katrina: Really? I just scribbled randomly
Katrina:  2分钟写完
Katrina: Finished in 2 minutes
Shure:  农夫山泉和娃哈哈
Shure: Nongfu Spring and Wahaha
Shure:  顺序反了
Shure: The order is reversed
Shure:  剩下都是对的
Shure: The rest are all correct
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is
Jake: 几分啊
Jake: How many points?
Jake: 大家都几分啊
Jake: How many points does everyone have?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on
Tasha: 这是谁的
Tasha: Whose is this?
Shure:  这是我的
Shure: This is mine
Jake: 好这个是我们
Jake: Okay, this one is ours
Jake: 从我们从宇轩的乌鸦的考卷开始是吧
Jake: Starting from Yuxuan's crow exam paper, right?
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Oh
Katrina:  3分
Katrina: 3 points
Lucia: 刚把这些都交回去了
Lucia: I just turned all of these in.
Shure:  哇哈乌鸦3分
Shure: Wow, the crow got 3 points.
Katrina:  f b这是b是对的
Katrina: f b, this b is correct.
Katrina:  对不起批卷老师有点那个哦
Katrina: Sorry, the grading teacher made a mistake.
Tasha: 4分天呐
Tasha: 4 points, oh my god.
Jake: 来大家看看有没有改错
Jake: Everyone, check if there are any grading mistakes.
Jake: 呵呵呵太典了
Jake: Haha, it's classic.
Katrina:  批卷老师批错了
Katrina: The grading teacher made a mistake.
Katrina:  然后去办公室找批卷老师要
Katrina: Then go to the office and find the teacher.
Jake: 乌鸦得了4分
Jake: The crow got 4 points.
Katrina:  天呐
Katrina: Oh my god.
Jake: 修硕几分啊
Jake: Shure, how many points did you get?
Jake: 你也是4分
Jake: You also got 4 points.
Shure:  但是我把怡宝选对了
Shure: But I got the Yi Bao question right.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 你选几分
Jake: How many points did you get?
Katrina:  我也是4分
Katrina: I also got 4 points.
Jake: 都是4分
Jake: All 4 points.
Shure:  呀
Shure: Yeah.
Alice: 3
Alice: 3.
Shure:  最后一个交卷
Shure: The last one to turn in the paper.
Shure:  和第一个交卷的人答案是得分
Shure: And the first one to turn in the paper scored the same.
Shure:  这个得分一样
Shure: They got the same score.
Jake: 几分
Jake: How many points?
Katrina:  2分
Katrina: 2 points.
Jake: 2分
Jake: 2 points.
Jake: 你为什么得2分
Jake: Why did you get 2 points?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 好这是3分
Jake: Alright, this is 3 points.
Jake: 2分3分一排4分
Jake: 2 points, 3 points, a row of 4 points.
Jake: 那决胜一下
Jake: Let's have a tiebreaker.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  石头剪刀
Katrina: Rock, paper, scissors.
Tasha: 他们仨
Tasha: The three of them.
Shure:  他仨
Shure: The three of them.
Jake: 怎么决胜呢
Jake: How do we decide the winner?
Katrina:  石头剪刀布
Katrina: Rock, paper, scissors.
Jake: 你们你们喝出吧
Jake: You guys, you guys drink it.
Jake: 你们喝出来这这这
Jake: You guys drink this, this, this.
Jake: 3瓶矿泉4瓶矿泉水的味了吗
Jake: Did you taste 3 bottles of mineral water or 4 bottles of mineral water?
Lucia: 两瓶纯净水两个矿泉水
Lucia: Two bottles of purified water and two bottles of mineral water.
Lucia: 只能看别的
Lucia: We can only look at others.
Lucia: 大概
Lucia: Approximately.
Katrina:  这这位不是专业嘛
Katrina: Isn't this guy a professional?
Katrina:  他说他
Katrina: He said he...
Shure:  我怡宝是能喝
Shure: I can drink Yibao.
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter.
Shure:  对怡宝真的是这里面最甜的
Shure: Yeah, Yibao is definitely the sweetest among them.
Alice: 然后农夫山泉有一点辣嗓子
Alice: And Nongfu Spring is a bit harsh on the throat.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice: 有点涩然后他没有味
Alice: It's a bit astringent and tasteless.
Alice: 然后他有一点点那种
Alice: And it has a little bit of that...
Shure:  好像
Shure: Seems like...
Shure:  好像只有农夫山泉是偏碱性的
Shure: Seems like only Nongfu Spring is slightly alkaline.
Alice: 就农夫山泉不太好喝
Alice: Nongfu Spring isn't very tasty.
Shure:  我也觉得
Shure: I agree.
Katrina:  哦我喝出来了
Katrina: Oh, I figured it out.
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter.
Jake: 好那这样吧我们
Jake: Alright, let's do this then...
Jake: 我来看一下
Jake: Let me take a look.
Katrina:  哎不对不对不对
Katrina: No, no, no.
Katrina:  嗯农夫山泉是几啊
Katrina: Uh, what's the number for Nongfu Spring?
Shure:  农夫山泉
Shure: Nongfu Spring...
Shure:  农夫山泉是一
Shure: Nongfu Spring is one.
Jake: 好这样吧
Jake: Okay, let's do this.
Jake: 我们来看一下各位手机的电量
Jake: Let's check everyone's phone battery levels.
Jake: 然后决定这个
Jake: And decide the winner.
Jake: 最后的赢家
Jake: The final winner.
Tasha: 我已经失败了
Tasha: I've already lost.
Shure:  我也是百分之18
Shure: Me too, 18 percent.
Katrina:  50
Katrina: 50.
Lucia: 96
Lucia: 96.
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow.
Jake: 哇
Jake: Wow.
Lucia: 昨天晚上刚充的电
Lucia: I just charged it last night.
Lucia: 早上就拔下来
Lucia: Unplugged it this morning.
Jake: 恭喜96号玩家
Jake: Congrats, player 96.
Katrina:  晚上也充了玩
Katrina: I charged it at night too.
Katrina:  玩到了50
Katrina: Got it to 50.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Jake: 好的那我们就按照这样的顺序
Jake: Alright, we'll follow this order.
Jake: 96
Alice: 96
Jake: 呃 96
Jake: Uh, 96
Jake: 先选礼物对吧
Jake: Let's choose the gifts first, right?
Jake: 一会我们会把每个人的礼物给拿上来
Jake: We'll bring everyone's gifts up in a bit.
Jake: 介绍介绍
Jake: Introduce them.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  嗯我们要自己拿一下是吗
Shure: Hmm, do we get them ourselves?
Jake: 对你们自己拿上来
Jake: Yes, you bring them up yourselves.
Jake: 然后我们把披萨也拿上来
Jake: And we'll bring the pizza too.
Jake: 你们就边吃边聊吧好吧
Jake: You can chat while eating, okay?
Jake: 然后这个水就当边吃披萨边喝就好了
Jake: And you can drink this water while eating the pizza.
Katrina:  好这是我的
Katrina: Okay, this is mine.
Jake: 这是你们的饮品
Jake: These are your drinks.
Katrina:  一天8杯水
Katrina: Eight glasses of water a day.
Lucia: 哈哈哈一天8杯水
Lucia: Hahaha, eight glasses of water a day.
Lucia: 这才6杯
Lucia: This is only six glasses.
Lucia: 还差两杯
Lucia: Two more to go.
Jake: 大家把礼物拿上来吧
Jake: Everyone, bring up your gifts.
Jake: 好吧一天可是一杯也没喝呀
Jake: Okay, but you haven't had a single glass today.
Katrina:  今天可是一杯也没喝呀
Katrina: Not a single glass today.
Lucia: 我看看我给里面装东西了吧
Lucia: Let me check if I put something inside.
Lucia: 别光带了个盒就搞笑了
Lucia: Hope I didn't just bring an empty box.
Shure:  没事客气了你
Shure: No worries, you're too polite.
Alice: 就出去倒点
Alice: Just go pour some out.
Shure:  我闻到有榴莲的披萨了
Shure: I smell durian pizza.
Jake: 我们把这个
Jake: Let's put this...
Tasha: 不是这个
Tasha: Not this one.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah?
Tasha: 没事不是
Tasha: It's okay, not this one.
Jake: 哪个
Jake: Which one?
Lucia: 这水把它掺一块
Lucia: Mix this water together.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Tasha: 卖苏打水和元气森林
Tasha: Sell soda water and Yuanqi Forest.
Lucia: 呃和元气森林已经喝完了
Lucia: Uh, we've already finished the Yuanqi Forest.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 这样我能节约点空间
Lucia: This way I can save some space.
Lucia: 给他两杯合一杯
Lucia: Combine his two cups into one.
Katrina:  磕
Katrina: Got it.
Jake: 对都喝吧都
Jake: Yeah, drink up everyone.
Jake: 然后这个披萨大家一起摆一摆
Jake: And then we can all arrange the pizza together.
Alice: 哎不得先交换吗
Alice: Hey, shouldn't we exchange first?
Alice: 先交换
Alice: Exchange first.
Jake: 边吃边
Jake: Eat while...
Jake: 边吃边聊
Jake: Eat while chatting.
Lucia: 本餐厅招募信息如下
Lucia: The recruitment info for this restaurant is as follows.
Jake: pizza Tuesday pizza first day
Jake: Pizza Tuesday, pizza first day.
Tasha: 榴莲的在这个箱子里
Tasha: The durian one is in this box.
Tasha: 啊哎
Tasha: Ah, got it.
Lucia: 怎么这么多啊
Lucia: Why are there so many?
Lucia: 还有小食是吗
Lucia: Are there also snacks?
Katrina:  鸡哥
Katrina: Hey Nicous.
Lucia: 这是小龙虾味
Lucia: This one is crawfish flavor.
Katrina:  我好想吃小龙虾
Katrina: I really want to eat crawfish.
Lucia: 那可以把小龙虾摆的靠那边一点
Lucia: Then we can put the crawfish closer to that side.
Lucia: 我没看错吧
Lucia: I wasn't mistaken, right?
Lucia: 上面写的好像是小龙虾
Lucia: It seems like it's written as crawfish.
Tasha: 这个和这个一样
Tasha: This one and this one are the same.
Tasha: 放到这哎
Tasha: Put it here, got it.
Jake: 这个是一样的吗
Jake: Are these the same?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yes.
Lucia: 照烧牛肉
Lucia: Teriyaki beef.
Lucia: 哦我以前很喜欢吃这个味
Lucia: Oh, I used to really like this flavor.